Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're doing something that
I'm very excited about.
We are going through all the things
or some of the things that
we have bought in 2020.
We're looking back on
2020 through the lens of
our Amazon Shopping Cart order history.
Yes.
This is your idea.
Well, actually the general
What was the genesis.
I the general idea was Stevie's idea.
Oh yeah, that's right.
In the Ear Biscuits topics
doc, that we all share.
And then forget to look at
until like six months later.
And this is like we were having
these conversations about
what people, everybody
was buying things new
in different ways.
And I know I was buying
things almost therapeutically.
Like in quarantine you
don't have a lot of things
to interact with other than your family,
you find yourself like going
to Amazon and thinking,
I do need that, if you're me, at least.
And so when she said, what
did you buy in quarantine?
That was like six months
ago she suggested that,
so now it's, what did you buy in 2020?
Because we're almost
done with the year, bro.
Yeah you can look back.
I mean, it's not that we bought
everything through Amazon,
but I mean.
It's the easiest place.
We are submitting to our
shopping corporate overlord,
it's just, you can't help yourself.
Well, I mean.
We buy local too.
Yeah, we're not gonna get-
Mostly when it comes to food.
Yeah, we're not gonna
get into a commentary
of the nature of buying so
many things through Amazon.
Matter of fact let's
not even mention Amazon
in this conversation.
But all these are gonna be Amazon links
and we're also gonna link all
the things that we talk about
in the description of both
the audio and video podcasts
with our affiliate links.
Because I mean, if you don't
end up buying some of the stuff
after I talk about it,
then I'm a bad salesman.
So you're telling me if
they click on the link
that we provide-
I don't really know how it works.
Then we get a little cut of it?
I think it goes, it might go to charity.
Honestly, all I know-
Is that it's fun to talk
about what you bought.
I feel like I should know how
the affiliate program works.
It's better if you don't,
because it makes us more pure.
'Cause I think it's actually very simple,
but I just have never asked any questions.
People are just like, oh yeah,
we have an affiliate program.
I'm assuming it's a
referral little stipend
but we're not doing this to make money.
No, no, it's interesting, well-
We're doing this because
you got a charge out
of buying these things
now you getting charge
out of talking about it.
Well, you might notice
there's a slight difference.
Now I went through my Amazon history.
Me too, I did as well.
Now let me say that,
this is not my wife's
Amazon and my Amazon,
we have separate prime accounts.
I don't know exactly
how that started, but-
So you're paying double.
Well, you can share accounts on the prime
but that dint work for me.
The reason I started it
is because I had to get her
presents through Amazon.
And I don't want her to know that
what I'm getting for different holidays
and birthdays and stuff.
Right.
So I'm sure there was a
smarter way to do this
but long ago I just
started my own account.
And so just to let you know
this is all things that I
individually decided to buy.
This is not what my kids wanted,
this isn't what my wife wanted.
That's a separate account.
And I picked out what I'm guessing is 10%
of the items that I bought in 2020
and I have 35 things to go through.
I went through my Amazon account,
which I share with Christy,
it's technically Christy's
account because you know
you wanna get the prime shipping.
And then the thing where
you can add my own account
to her account and link the prime shipping
to be shared by the family,
I didn't quite figure that out.
So the affiliate program is so complex
that you really need a degree.
I got time for that.
To get through it.
So the vast majority of things
that I look back through
on 2020 of my account,
everything our family
purchases is in there.
So you had to find the things that you
I had to like sit down.
Individually wanted and bought.
Yeah.
And how many things did
you bring to the table?
Four.
I bought slightly more things than that,
but they were just like.
There's a big difference, man.
I mean, yeah.
We got different personalities,
different disposition.
I didn't want one of my
things to be paper towels
or toilet tissue.
You picked the interesting
things that are related to your-
Most of the things I picked I think
there's definitely a story behind,
like I said nine out of 10 things
I did not put on this list.
We are very different people
when it comes to buying things,
maybe we'll get into that later.
But I'll pepper in some of mine.
I mean, I've only got four, so how do you-
Is one of them pepper?
How do you wanna do this?
Well, but we should get started
'cause I got a lot to talk about.
Yeah, go for it.
Now, some of these will have
some associated background
and some of it I might just say
and if you have a question
about them, you ask it,
if you don't, I might just move on, okay?
That's right.
This is in reverse chronological order,
so I'm starting with
the most recent things
and going deeper into the year.
Backwards.
I could have been made it more interesting
but it's this simple.
First item, Best Maid Dill Juice.
Dill Juice?
Dill juice.
D-I-L-L, okay you're
talking about pickle juice.
Yeah.
I know what this one is.
Right, it's 'cause I told you about this.
You made some hot chicken
sandwiches at your home.
Right, I made some-
This is a sore subject for me.
Yeah, well we can talk about that
because your wife had
some choice words for you
at the get together at your house.
I didn't appreciate that.
Well, I didn't say anything about it.
Well, what you did say was,
''tomorrow I'm making
hot chicken sandwiches,
I've done research and I'm
gonna make these at home.
Did you know that they brine the chicken
in Dill Pickle Juice,
and that's the secret.
And I'm doing this tomorrow
and we're really excited about it.''
And I was kinda locked in on Christy
as I was talking about it
'cause I knew that she would
care more than anyone else.
Oh and she did, and she was like,
''I'm excited about it
too, can I get one?''
Man I wish, and then she
turned to me, she's like,
''I wish you would do stuff like this.
I wish that you would like
come up with something to cook,
and then the next thing
you know you're cooking it
and then we're eating it.''
Right, that's kinda how it works.
I mean like, I didn't know what to say.
Well, it's fine because I
also closed talking about it
with the promise that I'm gonna become
like my own little pop-up.
And I'm gonna be making these things.
And I was perfecting this recipe
by doing it for my family.
And boy, I got it right on the first try
and so next time and I'm gonna
do this when I make brisket
and when I make pull pork
and I'm gonna make more.
I believe in this,
this doesn't make me mad.
I'm gonna make more than I need
and I'm gonna take some to my
friends including your family
for I'm free.
And you know what I'm
gonna do, I'm gonna gladly.
Eat it.
Take it.
But then if it becomes a thing
I'll be gladly to make it our thing
that like I could help with promotion.
Well, it's not a money-making scheme.
This is just a generosity
thing and in fact-
I can help with the content,
the ancillary content.
The last piece of the puzzle is pies.
I wanna figure out how
to make amazing pies.
Actually the whole idea I was
gonna call it thighs and pies,
but it's more than just thighs.
What about pie-thighs.
It's also a barbecue
and it's other things.
Chicken sandwich that's
made with the thigh
is the best man.
Nobody does that.
Lindsay who works with Jesse
was at the house last night
and she had been at the
house during the day
and I got home and I was like, where's,
'cause I made this this weekend,
and I had like six pieces
of this chicken leftover.
And I got home last night
and it was all gone.
And I was like, oh,
y'all ate all the chicken
and then Lindsay said, and she said,
''I ate a piece straight
out of the fridge cold.''
She said, ''that is the best fried chicken
I've ever had in my life.''
But it's not just fried chicken,
it is Nashville hot chicken, right?
Yeah.
So if you're saying that's
the best fried chicken
you've had, that's like
a different category.
Well, here's the thing
when I finished frying it
and I put it in the fridge
it had like the spicy stuff in the dredge
and like coating on it,
but it did not have the sauce on it,
which is a separate step that you do
after you take it off the grill.
But I didn't want the sauce to make
the breading soggy for leftovers.
So they just ate it just
a straight up chicken
so it kinda comes across like a Bojangles
like Cajun chicken, which
is really good, I mean.
And you deep fry it?
Yeah, I fried it.
A pan fry.
I fried it in like a three-quarters inch
of a peanut oil in a big pan.
Okay.
So yeah, just like four minutes, turn it,
that kinda thing.
Anyway, that's just one, I mean.
Keep going.
I can't talk about everything that much,
but that was a sore spot
because your wife is upset about it.
I'm gonna just-
She wasn't upset.
You might have to decipher
what it is I bought
because I'm literally
reading word for word,
the name of the title on Amazon.
Okay.
Kohler K four zero zero
nine, zero Reveal Quiet-Close
with Grip-Tight Bumpers,
Round-front Toilet Seat White.
Round front toilet seat.
I buy a toilet seat for my boys bathroom
because they're so rough on everything.
They broke it?
They broke the toilet seat.
Or they permanently stained it.
I think they sat too hard on it
or maybe they peed too hard on it.
Oh God.
And it was the kinda thing
that two boys in a bathroom
with a broken toilet seat turned
into two boys in a bathroom
with a toilet with no seat
for longer than we should
have let that happen.
The seat wasn't even all there.
No seat.
So they only peed in it.
Yeah, and they came to my
bathroom to take a dump
or the guest bathroom to take a dump.
And it took about six weeks
for me to get tired of that.
Oh gosh, did you think
about getting a cushiony one
that like it's got little holes.
Well, it's interesting
that you asked this because
when the toilet seat came and I said,
hey Shepherd, hey come here,
I'm gonna show you how
to install a toilet seat.
This is something
somebody you should know,
learn from your dad.
And the first thing he said, he was like,
did you get a good one.
I'm just like, what, was he
thinking about the soft kind?
'Cause I was like, what do you mean?
He was like, you know, like a good one.
I had a babysitter who had to get one,
old people they'll have
a cushiony one, and it's-
Sometimes they got carpet on them.
Oh my, yes.
That's the most unfamiliar
thing I've ever heard of.
I think you're getting something confused.
The Tod has got a lot of them.
A lot of old people they'll put
like a crocheted toilet lid cover,
but it's not on the seat
itself, it's just decorative.
I think that was a fad.
I think that the soft toilet seat
is asking too much out of life.
If you have a crocheted lid
and you lift that thing up,
you should be expecting
a, it's vinyl, I believe.
It's like plastic-y and
then it has like styrofoam,
like foam inside of it.
My grandma had one.
And when you sit on it
the first time, it's like,
oh, this is pleasant.
But then it starts to sprout leaks
and when you sit on it
little pinholes of air
will just come out around your hips.
It feels good though.
But then you sink down into hardness.
Well, all people have it I
think because as you get older,
you lose muscle and fat
and you got a bony butt.
So I don't have a bony yet,
I will, and at that point
I'll get a soft one,
Shepherd will be happy.
Golden Saffron
Lets move on.
finest pure premium all red
saffron threads, grade A plus,
highest grade saffron for
tea, paella, rice, desserts,
no artificial, no
Preservatives, two grams.
So this is-
It's another cooking
expedition, I've been on.
Yeah, a lot of cooking stuff.
I'll also just throw in big Paella,
22 inch carbon steel
Paella pan 55 centimeters,
bought at the same time.
22 Inch.
Yeah.
A two foot diameter.
It's a very large Paella pan.
Now, as you know, out in my grill area
that I just made an appearance
on, Fancy Fast Food.
I heard about that.
'Cause we smoked
some stuff for the McRib.
I didn't watch it, I wasn't there.
You may not have seen, but
I got a big burner out there
because I wanted the
option to make a big Paella
for a lot of people who come over
when the pandemic is over.
Predicament, the pan predicament,
you should get a name for it.
But again,
I'm getting my recipes on a lock
before I share them with my friends.
So I'm testing them on my family, and so-
You're really fixated
on the hosting component
and I think that is driving your culinary.
You know me, I like to create experiences
that's why I did the game night
and I like the idea of like,
hey everybody, we're gonna
have this giant ass Paella
that I made.
And I like to experience things.
You like to eat things that
other people make for you
listen so do I, nothing wrong with that.
I like to be served.
And as you know, as we
talked about on the show,
saffron is something that you
and I both didn't really like
when they made some kinda
saffron dish on the show,
we talked about how it
tasted like pool water.
What I learned is that a little bit,
I mean, a tiny bit of
saffron goes a very long way.
I used this tiny little pinch,
like four or five little
strands of this stuff
in like a 14 inch pipe.
It comes in threads,
is that what you've read in the-
Yeah, yeah, threads.
Like is it a plant or is it-
Well it's not an animal.
Well because it's golden
and it comes in threads,
I start to think of it
as like something like
Rumpelstiltskin with fabric.
It's like that little
threads that long anyway.
It's fabric.
I'm on the saffron train
'cause I'd know that a
little bit goes a long way.
And it just, my first Paella chicken
and also I got rice and chorizo from Spain
and it's absolutely heavenly.
I mean, you're gonna love it,
you're gonna absolutely love it.
I'll do it for you in the 22 inch pan
which I still haven't used
because I used the small pan
'cause I'm not gonna feed my entire family
with a 22 inch Paella, that's crazy.
It gets a bit fruit fruit,
like the fried chicken.
Paella fruit fruit?
But when you're like,
I got the thing from Spain and you know.
If you're gonna do it, do it right.
If I may.
You may.
When you're hosting people,
hold some of the details
close to the vest, okay.
Because you run the risk.
Oh, I'm not gonna tell
them what's in there.
If you're like, well,
you know, I got this,
it's kinda like.
I'm not gonna use that voice if I say it.
Yeah, you gotta give them a little bit.
If people are really interested,
then you can give them a little bit more.
But don't just give them everything like,
well, I sourced this from Spain
and I source this from Switzerland
and Rumpelstiltskin himself,
I got him on the phone.
You wait until you taste.
You wait until you taste the
Spanish chorizo, oh gosh.
I mean, I'm thinking about it right now,
my mouth is watering.
Let us taste it
and then see how much
of the details we want.
Here's something a little less exciting.
I mean, I got a list too.
I'll say this really quick
and then we'll hit yours.
I mean, you've got four
things I'm trying to like,
I gotta kinda get through.
But they're big.
AC Infinity MULTIFAN S7-P,
Quiet Dual 120mm AC-Powered
Fan with speed control,
UL-Certified for receiver DVR playstation
Xbox computer cabinet cooling,
if you can figure that one out.
Well, you got a cooling fan, for what?
For DVR cooling.
So, you know I've got
my media set up outside.
Right, I showed you that too.
And you saw we watched one
little YouTube video out there
I just gave you a taste.
Yes, yes.
But the receiver and I don't know,
I didn't set it up, I got a guy to do it,
but the components inside
the cabinet which is outside,
got so hot that I like
opened the thing and like
a heat wave, like burst into my face.
And I touched the side of it, I was like,
man I can fry an egg on this thing,
that seems like it could
burn my house down.
You might paella on it.
And so then I started trying to figure out
what the solutions were.
And so I bought these cooling fans.
So it's kinda like a fan
that would be in a computer
that you would.
Yeah, you can put them
in the door or you can
what I did is I made it where the door
is a little bit open up with some spacers
so that there's a big crack all
along the sides of the door.
And then I put the fans
in the front and they,
some of them pull air
in and some push it out.
So it brings in the outside
air and circulates it.
And it also, this thing
comes with a thermometer,
a thermostat essentially, that you can set
at what temperature the
cabinet has to get to
before they come on.
I mean, of course this exists,
but I didn't know about this
world of fans, now I do.
And you would put this in yourself.
Oh, it's simple, super simple.
That reminds me when I look back
through the Amazon history,
I started realizing how much
crap Lincoln has bought.
Like he buy fans, all
types of computer stuff.
He built a computer.
Last Christmas, he got a computer.
And then over the course of quarantine,
he has disassembled and
rebuilt the entire computer.
That's what you gotta do.
And he was like, you know what,
I shouldn't have bought
that pre-made thing
you gotta build it yourself.
They're on discord, shaming each other
about if they built their
own computer or not.
So now, but I liked the fact
that like this was his project
and he was figuring stuff out.
You know he fried his motherboard
because he didn't use proper techniques
to troubleshoot something.
There's so much LED situation
inside of a computer these days.
Just for show, right.
Just for show.
And he couldn't get all that to work
and he fried his motherboard
by touching the wrong thing
with it being plugged in.
You gotta have like gloves on
when you are working with that stuff.
You know what he learned his lesson.
But then he bought another motherboard.
Yeah, but with his money,
all of this stuff is with his money.
But it is through our Amazon account
and yeah, he went in debt
to get another motherboard.
But I was like, you know what,
he needs to experience the sinking feeling
of investing his emotional
and physical energy
into a project and then
totally tanking it.
And then having to figure
out how to start over.
That's an important life lesson.
I could see that, I mean,
the look on his face,
I was like.
You were there when it happened.
This is a good moment.
No, well, I got home from work
and he was like he had this,
Christy told me you should
go in and talk to Lincoln
and he's just in his room
just like staring dejected.
And he like confessed what had happened.
And then I taught him
how to do some googling
in order to really
figure out what was wrong
and what needed to be fixed.
So I didn't do it for him,
but I helped him figure
out how to develop.
You helped google.
I helped him google the right thing.
There's an art to it.
So I'm sifting through
all these computer parts
to get to my thing.
And okay, I guess in
reverse chronological order
incidentally, I feel
like I've talked about
all of these things in
one place or another.
'Cause I buy so few things.
Have I talked about my ultra slim wallet,
Slim Minimalist Front Pocket
RFID Blocking Leather Wallets
for Men Women, that's what it says.
I got it in my pocket.
I had a slim wallet for over 10 years
and the whole thing was falling apart
to the point where it had
a little plastic thing
that you could see the
driver's license through it,
just like this new one has,
but it had frayed open.
So every time I reached to get my wallet,
sometimes that little
hard piece of plastic
would wedge itself in
between behind my fingernail.
which is a form of torture.
How long did you deal with that?
Probably six years?
Like, no exaggeration.
My wallet was at that level
of dilapidation for six years.
And you know what, an
ad came up on Instagram
for an ultra thin wallet.
Yeah they knew you wanted one.
And I was like, you know what,
I'm gonna click on this
and I'm gonna buy it
and I'm gonna tell Rhett I did.
And he's gonna be so happy for me.
I actually clicked on an
ad and bought something.
Something I'd never do, ever.
Yeah.
So I did that, I dropped
like $23 on this wallet
and never got it.
Oh, about to say 'cause this is Amazon
so you had to go.
I never got it.
And this like, you got
one like it from Amazon.
I got one like it, I
was like you know what,
this freaking wallets never come in
I emailed them and told
them I want my money back
or give me the wallet.
No response, it just fizzled out.
The one time I take a
risk to buy something
based on an ad in an impulse kinda way
it blows up in my face.
That happened to me one time this year.
I think it has something to do with-
It's the only time I bought something.
I don't know what the standards
are for getting something
on Instagram ads, but
the process, and again,
this is one of the reasons
that so many people buy things
on Amazon.
It's like you're buying
from a kick-starter.
Yeah.
It's like
well, we're not really
making the wallet yet.
They haven't always gotten
their stuff together.
So, I got this wallet
and I've been carrying it
in my computer bag more
than I've been carrying it
in my back pocket.
It's not slim enough for you.
It is a bit bigger, so I'm not too happy.
My wallet is from an Instagram ad as well.
I've shown it to you.
I'm not going into my Instagram purchases
that could be a whole different episode
because I'm that guy who is
susceptible to advertising.
So I bought that.
What, a wallet?
You know what, I have so much
anxiety around buying stuff.
Like I was mad about that wallet, man.
I felt like, you know,
I learned my lesson,
never buying anything again.
Like literally that's how I felt.
And then I like had to
work have the energy
to buy that wallet.
I was like, man, maybe it's just a sign
I keep my old wallet.
We might get into the psychology
of that in a little bit.
But we do need to take a
break and make some money
so that I can continue
to buy things on Amazon.
And ironically, we're gonna
talk about amazon.com/mythical
because that is our Amazon store
where we sell things that
are exclusive to Amazon.
So a bunch of apparel.
Check it out.
We also have our entire
grooming line over there.
And there's a whole section,
we've got a divided by section,
where there's a section
called music and media
where you can go there
and you can buy like,
two of our musicality special, our books.
It's all in one place, so convenient.
I'm crying over here.
Check it out.
Yeah, 'cause you spent money on a wallet.
Lando asked me and so he's like dad,
I need some more mythical pomade,
the other stuff that
you got me doesn't work.
Off course it doesn't, yeah.
And I'm like,
of course here I am admitting that
I give my son other stuff.
But we just had some
extra stuff laying around
in that little window before I could get
more mythical pomade home.
And he insisted, he says, I can't use it,
it doesn't meet my standard,
only mythical pomade
meets Lando's standard
and my standard by the way.
Get it at amazon.com/mythical.
Mythical pomade the perfect
pomade for 11 year olds.
Okay, moving on.
I've already told the story about this
it's worth mentioning though,
United Ortho Short Air Cam
Walker Fracture Boot large black.
We talked about the boot
that I got for Locke.
Oh, fracture boot.
It's a fracture boot,
was not ever used by the way.
So I have a fracture boot if
you're in the market for it.
Never used.
He tried to use it one time and then
the next day was okay.
Lets move on.
You know, let's move on.
Metal Food Grinder attachment
for KitchenAid Stand Mixers
and includes two sausages stuffer tubes.
Okay, so I'm losing interest
'cause everything's cooking related.
This is a sausage maker.
It's a grinder that you
put on the KitchenAid.
Does it work?
Haven't used it yet.
You haven't used it.
I got it because I want
to pasteurize my own meat
and grind it so that I can have
a medium rare and rare
burgers and it'd be okay.
So you have to like flash boil
your meat to pasteurize it
and you can get like a better cut of meat
then you can grind it
and then you can immediately
patty it and grill it.
It is quite an experience.
Because you want it to be redder.
If it's really good meat, yes.
Okay.
Now this is not gonna-
You can get it In-N-Out or Shake Shack.
You do not want a pink burger
at one of those places.
Yeah, but if you want a really good burger
you just go to one of those places.
But they're not gonna use the meat
that I'm gonna use buddy role.
You know what,
I assume it's not just
you can talk about it
you actually also enjoy
the process as well, right?
You're doing this for your self?
I Don't just do things
like I talk about them
I didn't know we were
gonna do this episode.
No, this is throughout the
year I've bought these things
because now, okay, I'm
gonna show you a picture,
Link I can't show you the picture,
'cause my wife took it and
you're not gonna appreciate this,
but I also got
a 30 inch steel Hand
Hammered Cantonese Wok.
30 inch, what, diameter?
This walk, it feels much
bigger than 30 inches
I think the bottom might be 30 inches.
Like have you ever looked
in the back of a Chinese restaurant
and seen the woks they are cooking on.
I gotta wok, that is no lie this big.
And I am gonna also-
I could curl up inside of this wok.
Yeah, I have to keep it in the attic
because I can't find any
place big enough to keep it.
It's in the attic.
Yeah, and there it will stay.
Nope, because again, so I'm gonna have
like four or five different
things I can do for parties.
I'm so ready to cook for parties.
When the pandemic, I don't
know why I can't say the word.
When the pandemic is over,
we're gonna have the most kick ass parties
and I'm gonna be catering.
That's not how it's gonna work.
It's not like one day the
pandemic is gonna be over.
Well, there's gonna be a point
in which we can freely gather
without anybody worried about anything.
I mean, I'm just saying that
that's gonna happen eventually.
Now I'm going to,
and I don't want to know
what my Chinese food recipe
is going to be,
I've been thinking about
something in the Kung Poa space,
but anyway, I'm gonna be
able to make so much of it
that we could have 100 people over
and I could feed all of them.
I do understand this whole cooped up
and not seeing people.
And then you're channeling
what you can learn now
into something that can then
reach ultimate fruition later.
And it's not, the timing
of it is the fact that
we just finished the outdoor area.
And I cared about like the
media area with the screen
and then the barbecue area, right.
Those are the areas that I cared about
because this is my place where
I'm wanting to get it just right.
Give me the next one,
is it cooking related.
Not food.
BN-LINK Compact Outdoor
Mechanical Timer 24 hour.
Me and link, what?
BN-LINK Compact Outdoor
Mechanical Timer 24 hour
programmable dual outlet timer,
plugin waterproof heavy duty,
accurate for lamps, outdoor
Christmas lights, et cetera.
Okay, just a timer.
I haven't told you.
I don't know if I taught you about this.
A plug in timer.
One of the things that I'm
also going to do at the house
is I'm going to make with my son,
a cold plunge pool using an old
or a brand, actually, a new freezer.
This might sound dangerous,
but if you wanna get like
so I'm saying like, if you
wanna take a nice bath,
if you wanna do what the athletes do.
So what I wanna do is I wanna be able like
get in the hot tub and then get in,
I wanna do the cold, hot,
cold, hot plunge thing
and just send myself into a euphoric state
and then make prophecies.
But in order to do that,
if you wanna get a plunge pool
and you wanna like get a real plunge pool,
you're not gonna get out for
less than like eight, $10,000.
I don't wanna spend that kind of money.
But, what I found-
You gonna buy big pots with that money.
I found a YouTube rabbit
hole of these people
who are using top-loading
freezers to create plunge pools.
You talking about the type of freezer
that like a serial killer would
just dump body bodies into.
Bodies in yeah,
but you put your live
body in it with water.
With the lid up.
And if that lid goes down.
Well, you can get out.
Somebody should be supervising you though.
You push it, like a lot.
I don't recommend this
and this hole, the timer,
is that you only want to run it
you're gonna put water in there, right.
And the timer is gonna run every,
like in the middle of the night
it's gonna turn the freezer
on to cool the water
and then it's gonna turn off
'cause you also have a bag ice in there.
And you get where you can
monitor the temperature
and based on the weather,
you know how long you
need to run this thing.
And of course then before
you get in it, you unplug it
even though you silicone seal the inside
so that it won't leak.
You don't want the
freezer to be plugged in
when you get into it, you
know electricity is bad.
Yeah, Lincoln learned
that with his motherboard.
Yeah, so anyway, but did
you know what happened
during the pandemic?
Top-loading freezers sold out everywhere.
So I got all the ancillary pieces to this.
For this reason?
Nope, because people are
trying to store food.
That's a better reason.
They're all worried
about not having enough.
So everyone's like, we gotta get them,
all our meat frozen because
who knows what's gonna happen.
Because of what.
That makes a lot of sense.
Yeah, and so all these
top-loading freezers
that are the right size,
literally every big box store
that I looked like a couple of months ago,
completely sold out.
They don't know when they
were gonna be back in.
I haven't checked recently.
So you've got the timer.
I have got the timer, the
sealer, the thermometer.
I've got all the ancillary pieces.
I just don't have the freezer.
So when the freezers are back
in stock and they might be,
I haven't checked lately,
I'm gonna get one and you can come over
and take an ice bath anytime you want.
I know you love him.
A lot of things sold out
because the pipelines are screwy
or shut down for whatever components of
on any number or thing.
I was thinking about getting
a mountain bike, and-
And they sold out.
You cannot buy a new mountain bike.
'Cause everybody is like,
I gotta get outside,
I got a bike.
Yeah, so it's like, I
mean, if you pick a new one
you might be waiting six
months and that's a tenuous.
I mean, it could be a year.
Right.
So I didn't order one at all
and now I'm thinking man, if
I'd ordered one a month ago.
You'd have it now.
Well, I wouldn't have it
but I would be a month
closer to having it.
Just do it man, just go for it.
You need a new mountain bike.
You're doing it all the time now.
And your boy that you mountain bike with
just got like a awesome mountain bike.
I know he did.
That makes you look bad and weak.
So you need to get a good mountain bike.
I think he is having more fun than me
it's not jostling his-
Testicles
His tail as much.
I've still got a hard tail.
You've gotta get soft tails.
He's got a spongy tail.
You gotta be soft on
both sides of the bike.
I bet you there be one that
stung me if I'd have had one.
No, you would've gone right under it.
I go through all these
conversations trying to justify
and then I don't do it.
I mean, my latest purchase,
my biggest purchase of the entire year
I've been thinking about for over a year.
And I finally pulled the trigger on it
because Christy gave me such a hard time.
She was like, just get the television.
Oh, that's a big television.
I enjoyed it the other night.
Watch Us on it.
Yeah, 'cause the-
Not us, I didn't watch us,
I didn't watch like.
Good Mythical Morning.
I watched the movie Us on it.
Yeah, I was like, the wall
in our entertainment room
my TV was too small.
Too small, I know I didn't
say anything about it
but I thought it a lot.
It was dwarfed by the
wall and by the couch
and everything, it just
wasn't proportional.
But I bought that
television for that room.
Yeah, that was a good
place to watch things.
But, no I'm saying I bought the television
that was too small.
The one that was in there for years.
You went too small too early.
I went to small right from
the get-go and then I'm like,
I didn't wanna return it.
And then I was like, I don't
deserve a bigger television,
even though this was
too small for the room.
And then I'm like, every
time I watch television
I'm a little mad about it but then
I just can't justify buying one
of these bigger televisions.
The question you should always be asking
about a television is, is this too big?
Not is this too small?
If you're asking, is this too small,
the answer is yes and
you shouldn't buy it.
Is this too big?
You're in the right place.
You're getting close.
Yeah, and you know what, I finally did it.
A couple of weeks ago
I bought the television
and I got the Apple TV.
You know, the thing that
put it over the edge
was at Mike's house.
He's got an Apple TV and
I'm like, what is this?
What is this amazing image on your screen?
And it's just a screensaver like-
Of a city.
Slow-mo drone footage of
flying over Los Angeles.
And you can see.
Everything.
You can see like inside
of people's offices.
Like I stood in front of his television
and I just watched it.
And I was like, how do I get one of these?
And he was like, well, it's
the screensaver for Apple TV.
It won't look good if it's not for a K.
Won't look good,
so I backed into getting
this big old television
and I gotta say we're enjoying it.
And I should have done it years ago.
Yeah, think of all the movies
that could have been a little bit bigger.
A little bit bigger.
You'll never get that back.
Gotta go back and watch them all.
But I thought about for
a year before I actually.
Yeah, I don't typically think that long.
I think that might be your issue.
As soon as you think of
it, you just gotta do it.
LITERRA.
Can't do it.
Men's six pack running ankle socks,
low cut performance, athletic
custom cushion tab sock.
Okay, so you got some socks.
I pull the trigger on these
particular socks quarterly
because this is my only
way to combat the problem
of the missing socks in my family.
Now that I've got two boys who are,
I mean, Locke especially
comes into my room
and takes my socks and they
typically do not come back.
These athletic socks that
we need for working out
or walking or whatever.
There's just some sort
of monster that eats them
and so I'd have to like
reload six pairs quarterly
is the only way to just
remain socks in my house.
Are you still doing the
plan that we talked about
a while back, that was like
they're all the same type
and they're all the same color.
'Cause I've done that for
the most part and I love it.
And then your kid's socks are different?
Lincoln has the same socks.
Lincoln and I basically share socks.
Well, yeah, that's what me and Locke do.
And I'm sure Shepherd he's getting close
to being a part of that, yeah.
And so they're all the same color.
Essentially yeah, I mean,
these are all just white ankle socks.
And then I've got like black crew socks
and those are basically
the only socks that I wear.
You know what, I actually
bought some socks too
in preparation for-
Is that one of your four?
Me and Christy's trip.
Actually it's not, no.
Oh, look at that.
I was like, I'm not going
to put socks on the list.
I mean, I'm sure Rhett
wouldn't like me talking
about something.
I'm not gonna do that socks.
Like socks, I got some hiking socks
and I got some for me and
I got some for Christy,
they kinda matching, she hated them.
But I was like, you know
they're very functional.
Hiking socks are important.
They are important.
LifeBoard, Portable Floor to Enhance Yoga,
Pilates or Ballet Barre Exercise at Home
on Carpet or Outdoors.
Portable floor.
Yeah.
So a hard floor to go over carpet,
but there's no carpet in your house.
This was for my solo trip
and any subsequent camping trip.
I have to do my back exercises
every single morning.
And I was like, when I did my solo trip
before this most recent solo trip,
I didn't have anything and
it out next to Joshua tree
and I found a piece of
plywood that someone had put
next to a fire.
And I took that plywood and
I did all my back exercises
on the plywood.
'Cause you're having to put your knees
and then lay down on the ground.
Yeah, I had to do all the stuff
that you gotta be on a hard surface.
And so it turns out they
make this plastic thing,
that again, is for people who are like,
I'm gonna go do Pilates in
the grass in Central Park.
So I wanna have like a
board to do it or whatever.
It rolls up?
It's just two pieces that fit together
like this, like and they
kinda come together.
Did you use it?
Yeah, I use it.
I gotta figure out a better
way to travel with it.
When I'm doing the solo
trip, it was no big deal.
'Cause I got so much room
in the car for myself
but we're going camping with the boys soon
and I have to take it
and I don't know exactly
what I'm gonna do.
You could also use it as
a sun shield when you park
on the windshield.
It's too big.
But you can store it there.
You could strap it to the roof.
I thought about that,
but I got the tent up
there and it's just like,
I gotta put it under it or something.
You know what, put it in the attic
underneath that big bowl you bought.
Give me another one.
Okay.
And then I'll hit you with one.
YSENTO men's casual cotton shorts,
3/4 jogger capri crop-pants
below knee shorts with
pockets, light gray 34.
Okay, so long shorts.
Shorts that go past your knee.
Capri pants, I bought capri pants.
They are called shorts, which helps.
But if you wanna call them
capri pants, go for it.
Have I seen you wear these.
I like them comfortable.
No, I wear them at the house sometimes.
Do they have a drawstring
or do they kinda cinch
at the ends or are they just flapping?
It's just like sweats.
How's that going for you?
They're comfortable, I enjoy them.
You know as the weather
begins to cool down,
I can do my stretches outside in these.
But your cuffs still stays cool.
Given my knees are very warm.
Okay, next thing I bought was,
Utopia Care Scissors, silver 899.
Now these things are professional
grade texturing scissors
with finger inserts.
If you have small fingers,
you put these finger inserts in there
so that it's still tight on your finger.
This is a scissor that
it only cuts half of your
whatever's in it.
So it's like a thinning shear?
Yeah.
I've seen Ana use these on both of us.
And I was watching her closely.
And then I'm like, you know what,
I'm cutting my own hair in quarantine.
And my hair is so thick,
I gotta up my game.
So I had to buy some of these.
It's a bit scary to use
a thinning shear because-
'Cause you get close
to the base and you cut
and it's feels like.
And then you cut.
Cut and comb.
And then you comb it out
and all of a sudden, a huge
clump of hair comes out
that's like, I mean a handful.
And then you just-
You sure you're doing it right?
You keep doing it.
I mean, then your hair looks the same.
Well, Ana is not cutting my hair again
in the parking lot.
So I'm not doing it anymore but-
But you already you cutting
Oh, it definitely helped.
but it takes guts, man.
It takes approximately-
I won't do it.
The same amount of guts it
takes for me to purchase
a wallet or a television
or anything really,
to thin out my own hair.
But now you're ready for
any situation in which,
and you can cut my hair,
you used to cut my hair
for a very long time.
I'd gladly cut it.
Are you making a suggestion?
No, no, no, no, nothing.
What else did you buy?
Well, I will just say quickly,
I'm not gonna read the whole
thing 'cause it's too long
but I did buy a phone screen protectors.
I think I talked about this earlier.
I just found that the screen
protectors and the phone cases
that you get when at your provider,
like if you are like an
AT&T Verizon and whatever
and you buy that stuff
along with your phone
you're gonna pay really,
really high prices
for all this stuff.
Like one of those glass,
like tempered glass screen
protectors will be like 35 bucks
if you buy it at the store,
but you can get a three pack on Amazon.
Let's see, what is the
price of this thing?
Three pack for 1599.
16 bucks you get three.
This is something that I know.
I mean, for years I will be in
a place looking for something
and I'll be on my phone looking
at it from somewhere else
just because I'm like, man, I
could either have it right now
or I could probably get
it for 10% cheaper online
or get a slightly different one or
at least feel validated in my purchase.
And then I'll do that.
And even when it comes to
like phone cases or screens
I'll go through all of that trouble.
And then, you know what I'll do,
I won't buy anything.
That's like getting ready to watch Netflix
and you don't end up watching anything.
Yeah, you just look at the menu.
Right, don't be that.
I mean, there's no screen
protector on my phone.
I mean, I do have a case
but I don't have a screen protector.
I got that case for $7.
$7 case you see it's
just as good as anything.
I got this screen protector for $0
'cause I don't have one.
That's even better deal.
Exactly.
Seasense air horn jumbo, eight ounce.
Eight ounce, what do you mean like,
so like a canned air.
Yeah, this is from my rap
career, that's on the side.
I got this-
Emergency horn for boating.
When I went on my solo trip,
it's just a general sort of survival thing
also it's been shown to be effective
in scaring away mountain lions or bears.
But I also got bear
spray, which incidentally,
you cannot get on Amazon
because they will not ship it
to me in California.
And I don't know if that's a state thing.
I mean, they sell it on Amazon.
So the only way to get
bear spray is to buy it
from a retail store, like
REI and then go pick it up.
I got that too, but that's
not one of my purchases.
So did you walk around with a belt
with bear spray and a horn on.
I didn't end up hiking.
I couldn't, the place that I needed it
I couldn't get into because
the National Forest were closed
but I didn't know that was
gonna be the case before
because of the fires.
Did you blast the horn just to test it.
No, 'cause I feel like that's
like a fire extinguisher
and I, you know, it's limited pressure.
It's eight ounces.
I don't know how many
seconds that translates into.
Yeah, well it's a blast.
You should have bought
two just so you'll know
how long you have to blast.
Along that same line,
the next three purchases
which I'll go through quickly
were all from my solo trip.
Atomic Bear Paracord Bracelet, two pack.
Atomic bear.
So that's just the brand,
but this is basically a little bracelet
that's got a firestarter built into it
and also like a paracord.
It's just like, so you're
completely ready for anything.
This was really if I was gonna go in.
What do you mean that what
would you use with a paracord.
Like a parachute string?
Having rope I've been
told is very important
when you're in a survival situation.
I don't exactly know
what I would use it for
but I think if my life depended on it,
I would figure it out real quick.
Apparently rope is very important
because it's in all these survival things.
But you don't even know
how you would use it.
You bought a bracelet.
I bought a bracelet
that was a firestarter.
Yeah, and it also has a loud
whistle and an emergency knife
all built into just the bracelet.
I didn't know what kind of
stuff I was gonna get into.
Anyway it was real cheap.
I also got a 6.5 foot Pop Up
Changing Shower Privacy Tent,
Portable Utility Shelter Room
for Camping Shower Toilet
Bathroom Trade Shows,
Beach Spray tan popup.
Beach spray tan popup.
Green, yeah.
Okay, so basically a
shower curtain for camping.
Yeah, because I was gonna be
taking showers and pooping
just next to my car.
And I didn't know where it was I gonna go.
How did that go?
I never pooped or showered in a place
where somebody could see me.
So I just showered and pooped in the open.
So you didn't use it.
I opened it up one time to be like,
let's see what this feels like.
Okay.
I'm bringing it on our trip.
Did you start a fire with your.
No, fires were illegal,
you couldn't start fires.
See, and I don't like being this guy,
like what I'm doing to you
right now I do to myself
and nothing good comes of it.
Like, whenever I have
to shop for something
or whenever I find myself
shopping, I'm making a decision
as if I have to defend myself to somebody.
Like I'm treating you the way I feel like,
someone will treat me with
every single purchase.
Like I'm gonna be grilled and
have to justify everything.
Seriously, like that's how I-
But you're justifying it to yourself.
But that's not how it feels in my brain.
It actually feels like I'm gonna be,
what's the word where somebody
in a courtroom is asking
a lot of questions.
Interrogated.
Yeah.
It's interesting though.
That's not really,
that's more of like in a criminal.
Is interesting because-
But yeah, it's inner critic thing.
Well again, the ever-
And here I am putting it on you.
The ever teased Enneagram episode,
we're both self pres.
I'm a three, you're a self pres one.
And I think that's one
of the reasons that,
I mean, I'm also an impulse buyer,
but what I do is I tend
to envision a scenario
and I think about all the
things that I need to have
and be prepared for.
And then I'm like, oh man,
I'm gonna be like camping next to somebody
I just bought this toilet
that it's basically this bag
I'm gonna take a shit in,
I don't want somebody to watch me do this.
I wonder if there's some
sort of privacy thing.
And then all of a sudden
there it is for 20 bucks
and you just buy it.
And the fact that you didn't use it
it doesn't make you feel
bad about the purchase.
I want to have everything,
I wanna be completely prepared.
We're going camping in a
couple of weeks with our kids
and we're gonna be on
the road for a few days.
And I know that they're gonna want to,
I mean, you're taking a van
that has a toilet in it.
Yeah, it is.
But and you're not gonna
want everybody taking craps
in your toilet, right?
That's a conversation
we need to have, yes.
When they can take a crap in a bag
that I can just throw
into the trash somewhere.
That's probably preferable.
But I mean, my kids
don't wanna take a crap,
I might take a crap in
front of you and your kids
I got no shame.
That's a conversation we need to have too.
But the kids don't wanna do that
and so I've got a privacy thing for them.
Here you go.
I have an entire van.
So I am loosening up and
making some purchases.
I mean, I'm renting this freaking van
'cause I'm committed to van life.
My most recent purchase was
the smallest Nespresso machine
that they have.
Hold on, you have like a
really nice coffee machine.
Whenever we go somewhere
I always anxious about
what kind of coffee
machine they're gonna have
at the Airbnb.
Last, when I rented the
van for me and Christy,
one of the things that I
got excited about was like,
it comes with a Nespresso machine.
I did the tour of the van
and I didn't see the Nespresso machine.
I asked him, I was like,
where's the Nespresso machine,
oh, I gotta go get it from the house.
He almost forgot to put it in there.
I was like, thanks son.
How big is it?
It's like this big,
how many inches is that?
So like eight inches by four inches.
And you just put the Nespresso
pot, just a little bit.
It didn't work, it
didn't work on our trip.
I'm like, this is not gonna happen again.
Coffee is one of the key
components of camping in van life
so I'm gonna have one
that is a travel size
that I can take anywhere I need to go.
Any Airbnb, any type of thing.
So yeah, I got one.
So you've prepared.
Is that one of your four?
No, it's not, yeah this is one of my four.
It is not one of my four.
Oh, it is one of your four.
Well I mean, it's not,
it's not one of my four no.
Because when I searched
I went back further
and I thought we were just
going for weird stuff.
Well, I mean, it doesn't have to be weird.
But literally, I haven't
purchased much more.
But I did purchase this,
Fiskars 28 inch Bypass
Lopper black/orange.
What does that do?
It cuts limbs.
You know, my pomegranate tree
got all out of hand last year
and it had pomegranates all over it.
And so I didn't wanna trim it.
And I was like, now that
there's not pomegranates on it,
I won't feel guilty trimming her back.
How many pomegranates did you eat?
Not enough, that's why
I wanted to trim it back
before a lot of them grew this year
and I felt guilty about not
eating all the pomegranates.
Well you can bring some to me.
We're eating pomegranates.
Yeah, I made a lot of pomegranate jam.
You could be the pomegranate guy.
That's of course a lie.
It's not, you don't have to cook anything.
You just pick them, put them in a bag
and bring them to people.
I can have a pomegranate pop-up.
Yeah, and it's just pomegranates.
Pomegranates it's eaten raw.
I love a good pomegranate,
but when there's that many.
You have to give them away.
Yeah, they just rotting on the tree.
That's very sad.
'Cause yeah, that's why I got a Lopper.
I'll bring you new succulent barbecue
and you can pay me in pomegranate.
This thing could effortlessly
like lop off a pinky.
Oh yeah, there's so much
leverage in those things.
A thumb, like it could
take off a thumb easy.
Yeah.
Like I could lop off the end of your nose.
Well, that would be very easy.
In your sleep.
You can do that with
those scissors you bought.
You take off half of the
tip of my nose though
half of it would be a
'cause it's thinning.
I mean, I paid $26 for this thing
and I've only used it that one time.
There's a couple of
things I might wanna lop
and now I got something.
I'm gonna rifle through a few.
I got the Timber Ridge Zero
Gravity Chair Oversized Recliner
that was for trying to
connect with aliens.
We already talked about that.
I had some beans on
toast just for breakfast
and I took a picture for Instagram
and a bunch of people told me that
I had the wrong kinda beans.
And they were like, if you wanna do it
the way the Brits do it, you
need to get Heinz Baked Beans
in the turquoise basically pack.
So you bought that.
So I bought that pack of six
and while I was buying that next to it,
it's that people also
bought an airpod pro case
that was the can of beans.
So I bought that as well.
You bought beans,
and then you saw people
also bought an iPod, what?
Airpod pro case, for airpods.
The ear things.
That is a heinz baked
beans can shape as a place
to keep your airpods.
Wow, talk about an upsell.
Yeah.
That one had to cost four
times as much as the beans.
No, it was like, it's
rubber is like seven bucks.
Huh, oh yeah, it just goes over the case.
I don't know if I talked about this,
I got a glow in the dark
spill proof urinal for men.
Screw cap plastic male
urinal, portable urinal.
Where do you keep that, by your bed?
It basically is a jug with
a glow on the dark top
that you piss in
so you don't have to well
get out of your tent at night
when you have to wake up and
pee or to get up in the morning
and you're super cold
and you don't wanna get out of your tent,
you just piss in this container.
It's revolutionary, well, I'm
taking it on the camping trip.
You can't use it, but you can watch me.
No, do you ever think
about just inserting it
before you went to sleep
and then you wouldn't
even have to wake up?
It'd be like a giant
plastic sleeping condom.
No.
Yeah,
do you think about that?
I didn't, two piece Pack Portable Bidet.
That's just like what you,
I know you got one of those.
You actually have a nicer one.
I've got a little squeeze
one again that was,
Yeah, I got the tushy one.
Dint know what I was
gonna run into out there.
When I use the tushy one you can't use it
but you can watch.
A lot of people ask me
questions about this
'cause my wife tweeted a
picture of me earlier this year,
or she basically just tweeted
the picture of my tank top
that I was wearing.
It was the love tunnel
nineties tank tops for men
summer tease boys graphic
novelty sleeveless athletic,
tropical workout crew neck
shirts fit tank tops, L
which looks like this.
The titles are just ridiculous.
So it's a tank top the one I
got was the lion face on it.
Why did you get that?
A lot of people worried about me
and thought that this was
a new fashion statement
that I was trying to make.
And the reality is, is I
got this because I thought
we were gonna do more of those sketch,
those little Ticktocks
with Terry, the stepdad,
and I thought it would be funny
if he always had a funny tank top on.
And we never did it.
And we've never done it again.
I have that tank top
and also have one with
an American flag on it.
Also I have one with a cat in space on it.
I have all three of those.
You should bring those into the office
'cause it could be used
in a character sense.
If you keep them at home,
it means that you're
grown attached to them.
I found a good deal
on some PUMA Men's Roma Basic
fashion Sneakers, size 13.
As you know, typically the low
top white shoes that I wear
all the time, are Puma Romas.
Okay.
And I was like, I like these so much.
They're getting kinda old.
I kinda wanna like the
day I throw these out
I wanna already have the pair
like sitting in my closet.
And I found a deal on
them for like 40 bucks.
So I was like, and
they're still in the box,
because I haven't completely
worn out the other ones
but I'm ready for them.
So this is like I get this from my mom,
my mom the way she organized
our kitchen cabinets
was as if it was a grocery store.
So like, you'd finish one
bottle of Penrose sausage
and there would be another one behind it.
It's interesting because
I would think that
you would not want the same thing again.
Again, it's like, you're
enticed by getting something new
and getting something different.
They're just so comfortable.
I just like.
It overrides you.
I like the profile and
they're so comfortable.
I was like, I haven't
found a better low tide.
Except for like Allbirds, of course.
Oh, yeah.
They got a very comfortable low top.
I wear those a lot as well.
Can't wear them exclusively though.
But I also got Reeboks Men's
Royal Astrostorm Walking Shoe
Have you seen my Reebok Walking shoes?
No.
Well, you ought to see me walk in them.
I don't wanna see you walk in them.
We were doing so much walking
at the beginning of the pandemic
and I was not happy with the
way my feet were feeling.
And I was like, what is a walking shoe?
I've heard old people talk about these.
I found them Reeboks
apparently makes them.
Gosh.
Astrostorm.
You know what else I got?
What?
This is a REC, this is like early,
I mean, a recommendation.
This purchase wasn't
like a wreck with the W,
the OXO Good Grips Any Angle Broom, Silver
with a dustpan.
I love this thing so much
I made it a REC in fact,
back in April I think.
So I'm all the way back there.
'Cause that's a few things I bought.
I bought this broom, still use it.
I actually use this
broom so much I broke it.
And then I had it has a
like a bolting mechanism
that then will it'll swivel
'cause it's like any angle broom
and like it'll click,
click, click, click, click,
and then you can like sweep under stuff.
And I used it so much that clicker thing,
the internal mechanism, I broke it.
And instead of buying a new one,
I disassembled it and put
a nut and bolt in there
and I fixed it.
I made it stronger than it was originally.
I'm still using it.
Observation.
Very nice, OXO is a
nice brand for a broom.
So far with the exception
of the Nespresso machine.
And maybe the TV.
Okay yeah, the TV.
We got a broom, got some loppers
and I got some hair loppers.
Everything that you get-
And a wallet.
You got of Amazon it's very utility.
In fact, three out of
four are tools, right?
So it feels like, well,
I mean, a lot of the things that I bought
were based on something I was going to do,
it definitely feels like
I'm buying a lot of things
that bring me joy and pleasure.
And you're buying things
that you think that
there is a very specific use for,
that you think you can justify.
Easily justifiable, but the
broom does bring me pleasure.
I mean, I just use it to sweep.
But do you really enjoy sweeping.
I like, yeah, I like it.
But you know, I mean,
there's some deeply rooted things here.
I just think that growing
up there was this scarcity.
Now I'm not saying you grew
up rich or that you grew up,
you weren't spoiled
and you weren't spending
money left and right.
I know that's not how you were raised.
But I think for me,
there was this knowledge of scarcity,
like, oh my gosh, it's like,
I mean, we weren't poor
but things were tight.
And like, I had this
heightened sense of that
so it was like every single
thing that I would purchase
or ask for as a kid I just had
this real need to justify it.
Because I would feel like, you know,
if I get this Gi Joe Mobile
Command Center for Christmas,
I mean, how much less
money is that for us like,
use with something else?
My mom never talked to me
about any of this stuff
but it was just something
that I internalized
and interpreted my situation
as I don't wanna be the reason
that we go broke.
And I think that,
that's kinda stuck with me.
And it's not fun.
Well, I think that at this point
and look what my mom used to tell me.
But I could buy stuff now
and enjoy it like this.
My mom used to tell me,
well I hope you make a lot
of money when you grow up.
Like that's what she would
say to me all the time.
Because the way that I
would spend money as a kid,
like again, my dad had a good job
and we were well taken care of.
I mean, still definitely very
much in the middle-class.
But the interesting thing was
they didn't buy me a lot of things.
But what they would do is
they would give me money
for Christmas or something like that.
And then what I would do is
I would immediately spend
all of it, right.
Yeah.
I would say, okay, you gave me $50
for Christmas or whatever.
All right, let's go to Brendel's.
I'm gonna spend every bit of it.
Like why wait?
Yeah, I had a jar.
So I wasn't a saver, I've
had to be very disciplined
about saving as an adult, but
so that was my disposition already.
But I do think, and again-
It can I think simply just
be a personality thing
because when I look at my three kids,
like Lincoln, is that way.
Like he never has money.
Like the moment he gets money, it's gone.
And Lando will save up money.
I had a jar and I would like
meticulously roll up my cash
and my coins in it.
And I would say, I can buy this,
but I don't know something
else will come along.
I'm just gonna save it till something else
that like I really gotta get.
And I would look at the jar and feel good
you know sense of security.
Security, yeah.
Yeah, but Lincoln's
definitely not that way.
But Lily somewhere in the middle
and Lando is more like me.
So a lot of is personality based,
'cause I'm sure the circumstances.
And I know I mean I'm sure
there's something psychological
because I do impulse buy things
and I take comfort in
opening something up.
Like seeing a box, when
I get home from work,
seeing a box that was
delivered from Amazon
and seeing that it's got my name on it.
'Cause that means is for
me, it's exhilarating.
And sometimes I'm like,
I don't even remember what I ordered.
You know what I'm saying, it's like,
and so I know that there's
something potentially negative
about that process as well.
But I think that the
overarching thing for me
is neither of us make big purchases.
Like if we're gonna make a big purchase
like we're gonna do
this thing on the house.
And when I say big purchase like,
I mean we don't buy expensive sports cars,
we don't buy like boats or something.
I'm not saying we would never buy a boat
or something like that if the
opportunity presented itself
but we don't spend a lot,
we don't buy big ticket items.
In fact, sometimes we
don't because we didn't
like when we started our careers,
when we were on Santa
Campus Crusade well like,
we were making very little money,
like our early marriage both
of us had the same salary.
I mean, I'll just say what
it was because I remember it,
we raised $42,000 a year
that was the salary.
And in North Carolina, 15 years ago,
$42,000 a year it's not a
lot of money for a family
with a couple of kids, right.
Like you have to budget and
you have to kinda think about
what you're buying.
And I think that we've
taken that mentality
as we've made more money,
we've still maintained what,
again we sometimes we have
to ask our accountant like,
can you tell us how we're
doing with our money?
And they're like, you guys
are both very conservative
because you don't spend a
bunch of money all at once.
Like yes, there's a bunch
of items that's on this list
but for me, I feel this freedom
to spend 10, 20, $30 here and there
on this kinda steady stream of
pleasurable items for myself
because I'm not dipping in and going out
and buying like $100,000 sports
car or something like that.
I don't do that.
So I feel like I'm not
being irresponsible,
but I honestly I get a lot of
pleasure out of these things.
Like when that giant wok shows up
and I think about what I'm gonna do in it
and the experiences that
it will translate into.
Like it brings me a lot of joy.
And listen, it's a
privilege to be able to buy
the amount of stuff
that I'm talking about.
I understand that I have a lot of money
relative to a lot of people.
And so I can freely buy
these smaller ticket items
without really thinking
about the overall impact.
I'm in a privileged position.
And I know a lot of people out
there do not have the means
to do that.
But what I'm getting at is you do, right,
if everything's 50, 50,
you do have the means.
I've loosened up some,
I mean actually buying the television.
And I was like you know what,
once I actually clicked
purchase, then I was like,
I can't wait for this thing to show up.
And you haven't felt
guilty about it at all.
No, so I think that's good.
Yeah, it's not like every
time I go in that room,
I mean, I would come down in the mornings
for the first couple of
mornings and you know,
I don't have to walk through
that room to go make my coffee,
but yeah, I would kinda go.
Take a detour.
I would take a detour and I go in the room
and I'll just look at the television.
I mean, it will be off, the
screensaver wouldn't even be on.
After an hour, I think that turns off.
Yes, I would look at the
blank black of television
and I'd experience a little happiness
and then I go make my coffee.
Well, think about if you
get had other things.
If I had a walk.
No, you have definitely
changed a lot in that regard.
I've still got like 10
things I gotta get through.
I gotta get through my list, man.
People wanted it.
I'm done with my list.
Darrell Lea Original Black
Licorice, pack of two,
best black licorice that I have found,
I've tried a lot from Australia.
You only got two, it's a pack of two,
but there were many in the pack?
Well, lots of little pieces in there.
So soft, scrape, it's
got a great rich flavor.
Sensual massage oil with
relaxing lavender, almond oil
and jojoba for men and women.
Well, that's okay, keep going.
Let's just skip that one.
Summit Mosquito Dunks, 20 Dunks.
Mosquito dunks.
This is a little doughnut
that you can throw in standing water,
and it will prevent mosquitoes
from making eggs in there.
This is when they were doing
construction on the house
and then they dug the
pool out and it rained
and there was just stagnant water.
Had to dunk those mosquitoes, had to dunk
all those mosquitoes.
Did that work?
Well, I mean, I didn't see any babies.
Puriya Chest Rub feel instantly better
when you rub this aromatic
blend of peppermint, eucalyptus,
tea tree and lavender on
chest or under the nose.
Okay, so vapor rub.
Is a natural vapor rub.
I use it in the morning
before I do like my stretches
and in my meditation because
I have a deviated septum
and it helps open things up.
XJS Metal Compression Spring
Silver Tone, 40 pieces.
Another item along with this
is the BUYGOO 120 piece
Wood Square Blocks,
one inch blank wooden cubes.
This is an art project
that Shepherd and I started
and did not finish.
Woodblocks?
Shepherd and I had the idea to create
a Fibonacci sequence sculpture which was,
you can do the Fibonacci
sequence and you can do it like
a top-down view of the spiral
and it's got the rectangular blocks
that are the right proportions.
And we were gonna do different colors
and make like a full-size thing
where all these little
woodblocks are on springs.
And so you can touch it and it'll shake.
But they're all, it's the Fibonacci,
me and shepherd are kinda like,
we have a connection over
the Fibonacci sequence.
We like once tried to find one
that was in a park somewhere
and he's was fascinated by.
I remember, yeah.
So we painted all the blocks,
but then we ran out of one
thing and we had to stop.
So the whole thing is like in a box,
ready to be picked up at some
point, probably when he's 30.
Okay.
Black calypso beans,
OliveNation Cannellini Beans
or Cannellini beans.
Susie Q's Santa Maria Style Pinquito Beans
or Pinquito Beans.
That was three different beans.
I'm tracking.
I'm getting back to the
beginning of quarantine,
I stocked up on dry beans,
didn't know what was gonna happen.
Finally, the last two items,
Work Sharp Knife & Tool
Sharpener Ken Onion Edition
If you need me to sharpen your knives,
I have a knife sharpener.
Ken Onion.
I don't know if Ken onion
is a man named Mr. Onion
or it's the guy named Ken
and this is the Onion Edition.
I don't care though,
it sharpens my knives.
And finally, my first purchase of 2020,
Cap Barbell Coated Hex Dumbbell
with contoured chrome
handle single 60 pounds,
bought two of those.
You bought weights.
I already have the dial
weight, Bowflex dial weight
that gets you up to 52.5 pounds.
I was like, dude, by
the end of quarantine,
I'm gonna be too strong
for 52 and a half pounds
in each arm, I gotta go to 60.
How are you using those.
You know, bench.
You're using them.
Yeah.
Okay, good for you.
Yeah, when you wanna go deep, yeah.
Wow, what a journey,
what a journey.
You wanna here it, I don't
even have an attic by the way.
Yeah, well you do, we found a rat in it.
Oh, I wouldn't call that an attic.
But it's not an attic
you can store things in.
Yeah, I call that a rat space.
Right.
I bought a rat trap after that.
I dint mentioned that.
Did it catch anything?
Yeah.
It caught more rats?
How many?
Two.
Oh, you got the one.
And then I bought some whole sealer
that stuff that foams up and
fills holes, no more rats.
You got one of the rat traps
where they stick their
head up into it and it's a-
Instant kill.
Air compression bolt to their head.
It's electric shock.
So this is an episode full of RECs.
Do you have another REC?
No.
It's basically like,
take your pick from what
I just went through.
I gotta say some of my
favorite things on the list,
you know in terms of like
one of the cheaper items
that if you're into black licorice,
A, you have good taste
and B, I do recommend Darrell Lea.
It is that soft Australian style licorice.
And it comes with a
little story on the back
about how they discovered it,
because there it was like an accident.
And some of the best things
that are ever discovered
are because of an accident.
That you know they were typically
making this hard licorice
and he left it out too
long or did something wrong
and it came soft and it turns out that
that is the way to enjoy black licorice,
Darrell Lea, man.
Is that your REC?
have something better.
Yeah.
Wow and the gear is not even over,
you'll probably keep buying stuff.
Oh, I got some stuff on the way.
I didn't wanna talk about that.
#earbiscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.